التصريحات حول كيفيه التعامل ميساء مع
زواجها ودعوتهن الاحترام والشيء من الخضوع
اقله بالكلام دائما تثير الجدل هذا المنح
عادته مؤخرا تصريحات الاعلاميه المصريه
ياسمين العز تصريحات تثير جدلا واسعا في
مصر ما يجعل الاعلاميه شابه تنجح في تصدر
ترند على محركات البحث من هذه المواضيع
التي اثارت الجدل والنقد مؤخرا مجموعه من
النصائح للزوجات في كيفيه التعامل مع
الازواج كوضع القاب لزوجها اثناء نداءه
وعن ترك مساحه اكبر للرجل في خزانه
الملابس وتحدثت ايضا عن معاناه الزوج عند
خروجه مع زوجته للتسوق فاجات المشاهدين
بتصريح يقول ان تصرفات الرجال مع النساء
هي من روح الفرعوني
على جوزك كده يا محمد حاجه مثلا
قولي لجوزك يا استاذ محمد احمد ابدا معك
هل انت مع تفخيم تمجيد تعظيم الى درجه
الخضوع للزوج حتى يرضى عن زوجته
[موسيقى]
ما فيش حاجه ما فيش احترام من ناحيه واحده
الاحترام متبادل ما بين الشخصين فلو
الدنيا هتمشي انا اقول لمراتي يا استاذه
يا استاذ ده مش منطقي احنا كده مش متجوزين
في سنتر يعني لكن انا شايف التصريحات اوفر
جدا هي مجرد مثيره للجدل التصريحات ديت ما
فيش تصريحات بالشكل دوت ما فيش علاقه
زوجيه محترمه
بالشكل طبعا
انا طبعا مع الاستاذ ياسمين ياسمين عز
فراشه الاعلام المذيعه الجميله الخلوقه
الافكارها كلها
للاسره اللي بتاكد دائما على القيم
الجميله اللي تربينا عليها مع اهالينا هو
ده كلام امهاتنا هو دوت كلام قرايبنا هو
دوت كلام اخواتنا الكبار علشان نعمر
بيوتنا ونستمر في علاقه زوجيه سعيده
اساسها الاحترام المتبادل انا شايفه انها
ما قالتش حاجه اا جديده تستدعي مننا
الهجوم عليها بل بالعكس كل افكارها بتدعوا
للترابط الاسري والسعاده الزوجيه واحترام
الاخ واحترام الراجل وكينونه الرجل
اذا كانت المراه همم تقدر زوجها وتحترمها
وحتى بل يعني تقول لمن الالفاظ ما تعطي
مكان حتى كلمه سي السيد او لقب سي السيد
همم ابو العيال الى اخره من هذه الالقاب
غلط انا انها تستخدم المراه استاذ
استاذ
هقول لحضرتك حاجه
يعني هي انا قلت خير الامور الوسط انا مش
لازم عشان مراتي تحترم
ني تقول ان انا اولدي مدرس انا والدتي
عمره ما قالت له يا استاذ محمد عادي يعني
فهي عمره ما بيكون هي عادي ما تقولش ولا
مش عادي انك تقول الود مش عادي ان هي تقول
زوجها يا استاذ تقول له ازاي يا استاذ ليه
ايه الغلط ايه الغلط تقول له في البيت يا
استاذ هتقول له يا استاذ احمد
ههه لا طبعا مش لازم الكولاجين ناخذه عن
طريق الضرب بصراحه ههه انا مع ضد ضد العنف
ضد المراه تماما تماما تماما انما انا مع
احترام الطرفين كلاهما لبعض بطريقه تبيننا
قدام اولادنا وانا كسبت متزوجه من حوالي
24 سنه انا ماشيه بالمنهج اللي بتقول عليه
الاستاذ ياسمين الاحترام والود المتبادل
علشان نخلق حتى جيل متربي على اسس علميه
ونفسيه سليمه بيسودها جو من الاحترام ما
بين الطرفين عشان الاسره تستقر
[موسيقى]